Okay, let me just check the volume
sounds okay. Let's get started this week.
We're going to continue our discussion
of musical form and we're going to fold
that discussion inside
of the preparation for,
there's a concert which is
when Saturday and it is where
Battell chapel should be on the
sheet there and it's at 8:00 PM.
And we're going to have the Saybrook
orchestra perform for us today.
We're going to talk about a theme and
variations and one of the pieces that's on
that concert.
And then on Thursday we're going to have
the conductor and several of the solo
was come in and talk to us about the
difficulties of this particular con
concerting sort of get us alerted to the
sort of thing that we should be on the
lookout for as reviewers.
We will be continuing with this of course,
uh, in sections of this week and
when you come to lecture next time,
we will give you what I call a prep sheet.
Let's start with the guide to all three
pieces that are going to be performed.
And then when you go to
section, you will get, um, a,
a sheet and having to do
with how you write a review.
It's a whole list of sort of do's
and don'ts and writing and review.
Those of you that are are,
are in the Monday section.
We will work this out in advance.
We'll talk about that on Thursday,
but you may be encouraged to
come to an earlier section a,
and if that doesn't work out,
we're going to reform those
Monday sections in a way
that will work for you as
well. I know there are a
couple of students also, they
can't be here this weekend.
It's inevitable that that's the case.
Uh, there will be a makeup concert,
a scheduled at a later date.
So don't worry about this,
but do keep coming because the principles
involved in writing a review for this
particular concert or identical to
whatever concert, uh, uh, you attend.
Any questions about that
before we get started?
Yeah.
Okay. If not, let's go ahead and with
a concert program. It's kind of fun.
I started with this way early, the
last, uh, August arranging this.
What I wanted to do was
get a concert coming, uh,
in the middle of the term because I
think you're ready now to go at this a
serious material concert in the middle
of the term performed by an undergraduate
orchestra on in which the program
would be sort of user friendly.
It would be the kinds of things
that we had been working with.
So I contacted a couple of ensembles,
uh,
and the Saybrook group a one
had the best program and to uh,
seem to be quite responsive
in getting back to me,
but some of the things that we might
do and indeed one of the pieces,
the Brahms that we're going to talk about,
I suggested that they do because I
needed for teaching purposes in here,
I needed a good theme and variation piece.
Uh, and I've got one in the Beethoven,
but, uh, it's not quite as clear
cut as this particular one.
So as you can see,
we have three pieces on this concert.
I hope you all have the sheet
there. They should be listed, uh,
the overture to the marriage
of Figaro by Mozart.
This is an overture and
opening to his opera.
The marriage of Figaro and good
news here is that this spring,
the Eo Opera Company and
undergraduate opera company,
we'll be performing the marriage of
Figaro and his apps is an absolutely
delightful opera. I mean, it's to die
for, not only is it lots of fun and funny,
but it happens to be in terms
of the craftsmanship involved,
arguably the greatest opera ever written.
So we're fortunate to have it here
and you'll get a preview of this, uh,
this Saturday with the
overture that we will here.
Then we will go onto a piece
by Johann is Brahms. Uh,
anybody know anything about Brahms?
Um,
they're interesting characters
in the history of music. Wagner,
he might've been an sob, but
nonetheless, he was interesting.
Mozart is endlessly fascinating. Bach is
interesting in its own way. Beethoven, uh,
uh, sort of the prototypical
romantic genius. Very interesting.
I can't say that Brahms is a person's
personal life was all that interesting.
So maybe we'll just forget about it. We'll
just say that it was born in Homburg,
Germany and he died in Vienna and I,
I may have put his dates on,
on your sheet there.
Uh,
but he is of course one of the three B's,
uh, who are the other two in
the history of music. Of course.
Okay.
And Beethoven, I once ask
in a quiz in here, uh,
who are the three bs of music
and a student answered Bach,
Beethoven and Heiden. I was very
depressed for the rest of the day, but,
but Brahms indeed is the third be
here. Uh, so we don't want to forget,
get about him. He's a very
serious composer. He takes
everything very seriously.
I think I put on your sheet there.
Did I or did I not?
The kinds of things that he wrote.
Yes,
I did a four symphonies to piano
concertos, a violin concerto,
many overtures,
many songs,
much great chamber music. If you're a
violinist and you'll get rather advanced,
you can play the beautiful,
beautiful Brahms Violin Sonatas.
If you're a cellist and you
get reasonably advanced,
you can play the beautiful cello Sonata.
So he wrote a lot of really
great chamber music. Oddly,
he wrote no program music and we'll talk
about that a little bit later on what
programs is and he wrote no opera.
Well, so we'll a little bit different.
It very much sort of heavy duty,
instrumental, instrumental music. Well,
let's talk about this. Uh, composition.
It will not open the piece.
It will be the second on the concert.
It won't open the concert
would be the second piece. Um,
a set of variations on a
theme by Josef Haydn. Well,
the theme probably isn't really by
Josef Haydn, but when bronze got it,
everybody thought it was by Josef Haydn
is probably just a religious folk song
in honor of Saint Anthony, but
that's neither here nor there. Uh,
the shape of this, a
song or theme that, uh,
a bronze is working with here is
one that we're very familiar with.
Now instead of putting a, B, c,
B, I could have done that up here. I'm
going to flesh this out a little bit.
What goal is going to call this antecedent
consequence extension consequent,
but it's the same. It's the same form
that we saw in the Beethoven's Ode to Joy.
So it's a familiar organization for a,
uh,
a musical theme, sort of, uh,
opening, closing, extension,
and then closing again.
And in this particular set of variations,
Brahms, we'll do this,
which of course is our what?
Sign again?
Yeah,
repeat science. So he's going to repeat
each of these two sections. Actually,
Beethoven did that to some
extent that he owed your joy too.
So he's got this very straightforward
theme with that particular form.
Let's listen to the theme and
we'll try to pick up where the, uh,
antecedent concludes and where
the consequent begins. Oh,
and before that we could, we could plug
in another information. What's the meter?
Ask yourself as you listen.
What's the meter of this?
What's the mode major or minor?
What is the base doing?
What string technique is
the base employee in here?
Okay, that's the consequence. Now he's
going to repeat it. Let's go back.
We'll just move. We'll, I'm sorry. We'll
just continue on wherever you are. Linda.
Doesn't really matter. Are we continuing?
Okay, let's just continue on. Repeat.
Here's the antecedent.
Here's the consequence.
Yeah,
yeah.
Extension,
rising melodic sequence.
No, he's going to bring it back
down. Descending melodic sequence
and the consequences.
Yeah,
pause it there. Um, at this point,
what he does is take that bomb,
that tonic pitch and extended for a long
period of time. It's down in the base,
it's being held it,
this is a device that derives from
Oregon technique where organist,
we just put his foot or her foot on a
particular key and just hold it for a long
time.
So we call it pedal point.
So what Brahms is doing here is sort of
extending this tonic harmony by means of
a pedal point.
So let's listen to this.
Ah,
and now we've got to repeat,
I believe.
So we're back to the extension
going up the sequence.
Now back down.
Here's the
panel.
Okay, so go ahead to the next
spot. So that's the theme. It's,
it's rather straight forward and
really quite and quite lovely. Uh,
the solo instrument there of course,
wasn't oboe solo oboe there.
So now we're going to go one.
We're not going to go to all
these variations on your sheet.
What about these timings here? Can you
come in with a stop clock and, and have,
have your or watcher?
It's set in a way that it,
two minutes and 19 seconds.
You expect the first variation to come in.
Is that going to work,
Oscar? Why won't that work?
A conductor might interpret
things his or her own way.
We're gonna have both a male and female
conductor a on Saturday night. Uh,
so yeah, exactly. Um,
because different conductors
have different ideas about tempo.
Brahms would right allegro essay
or something like that rather fast.
But how fast is rather fast?
So they're not precise indication.
So these times are approximate here,
but I'll give,
give you a sense of when
things might happen.
So we're going to go on now
to variation five, I believe,
which is at eight minutes and 36
seconds or an approximation there.
Up and here we're going to give you
maybe the most difficult of all the
variations for the orchestra to play.
It's very disjunct rhythmically.
They're not altogether.
It's very contrapuntal.
Counterpoint is always harder to play
in an orchestra than homophonic because
every we've got all these things
that have to be coordinated. Um,
so let's listen to this.
If things,
if things seem muddled and unclear
in a performance of this piece,
my guess is it's,
it may well happen here,
but let's listen just to do a little bit
to show you how difficult and how far
away from the theme Brahms can go.
So we'll stop it there. So it's hard for
me even to get in terms of the rhythm,
there'd be absolutely sure where the
beat is because there's so much think of
patient.
I think that's a very fast one.
Two with the triple subdivision
under underneath. Uh, but again,
the point there may be, Gee,
I didn't remember hearing God,
where'd that thing go as hard to here?
Well,
he was varying it so much that he's
pretty much totally disguise the theme at
that point.
Uh,
let's go on now to listen to
a little bit of variation.
Seven, uh, uh, at 1103 or thereabouts. Uh,
this is my favorite variation,
but let's listen to a bit of it.
And see if you like it too.
There's the a section
come see
back to
now, what am I doing up
here? What is this? Well,
what I'm trying to do is indicate
what we call a compound meter.
It's one of these with,
you basically have a two,
but you have a triple subdivision and
conductors. If if that two is slow enough,
might go one, two, three,
four, five, six one, two,
three, four, five, six. So
it'd be interesting to see,
maybe we should ask the
conductor, uh, on Thursday how,
how he or she I f I forget who's
conducting exactly which pieces here,
how he or she is going to conduct,
I was going to do yard duty,
Dee Dee Dee a very slow to like that
or are we going to really show the
subdivision?
If he's showing this subdivisions,
that's probably a suggestion that maybe
he doesn't or she doesn't have quite as
much confidence in the orchestra and wants
to really show that beat very clearly
rather than with a working with a very
experienced group where you're just kind
of give the large patterns and there'll
be able to put it all together.
Now as we continue with this,
let's move up to a to
18 or 1218 please Linda.
We are now at this spot.
We're going to have the extension and
it's kind of fun to watch what Brahms is
doing here.
Brahms is obsessed with rhythm and it
drives you nuts when you're a performer of
this stuff. One, he's obsessed
with variation and two,
he's obsessed with rhythm.
He will change things even when
he doesn't need to change things.
And I remember a company,
my last child in the Brahms cellos Sonata
and I would have to continually change
hand positions for no good reason,
which is kind of arbitrary that he wanted
maybe just a slightly different sale,
whereas the sound before the Beethoven
would have been satisfied with in Mojo it
would have been satisfied with,
uh, wouldn't suffice for him.
So he's obsessed with variation.
He is obsessed with rhythm and it,
and as we listen to this passage, we will
see the basic one, two, three, four, five,
six, one, two, three, four, five, six
and then suddenly he will change it.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, one, two, three, four,
five, six, one, two,
three, four, five, six, uh,
emphasizing this way that in
music has called Hemiola, uh,
is probably some kind of Greek root
they're having to do with twos and threes.
I'm not really sure.
Uh, but as you can see,
we've got what we had was in
effect two units of three.
Now we've got three units of too.
I remember Leonard Bernstein.
I don't know whether it's west side
story or not yet. The t, t, t, t, t, t.
T. T. T. T. T. T. T. T. What is that
from? Is it from west side story?
Okay. Uh, so that's a good
example of Hemiola too.
I think it's called America
or something like that. Uh,
so that's what Hemiola is when you're
rolling in one of these and you suddenly
shift to the other back
and back and forth.
So let's listen to a love this lovely six,
become three groups of two,
one
by one,
five, six. Let's do that again.
Let's do that again. It took me a
while to find the, the six beat there.
So go back and a little before.
So here's e
bye.
And then he goes back.
Okay, well that's just the, um, a
little rhythmic Philip there, uh,
with Brahms. But it's the kind of
thing that keeps interest in his music.
Now we're going to go on
to the last variation a,
and it's an interesting one because
it's got two things going on here.
He's got a theme and then he's got
what we call an Ostinato. And music.
Anybody remember? I think we bumped into
this term before what an Austin auto is.
What does an Ostinato do,
Roger?
Good. That's it. Exactly. Uh, from
the Italian Austin Ra obstinate.
And it just repeats the same phrase
over and over and over again.
So what he's got here repeating oddly,
is in the base.
There's this tonic
escapes from repeating over
and over and over, uh, uh,
above which we have a very
distant variation of the theme.
Doesn't sound like the theme very much.
So let's listen to the Austin Natto
and this highly varied theme up above.
Can you hear the bass
notice salsa? Yuck. Dee Dee Dee tee tee.
What's he throwing in
against his basic beat? Yeah.
Tha Tha tha tha tha.
Tha. Tha. Tha. Tha. Tha
what? What's that? We've talked about it
before. We're beat. We're coming on here.
Ball ball one to one
and two and one and two.
And Yachty. T. T. T. T. T.
T. T. T. T. T. What's that?
Triplets. Okay, so we
talked about that before.
So here he's making this more complicated
rhythmically by not only using Hemi
Olin syncopation, but also threes
against two simultaneously.
He's throwing in some triplets
in the melody up above. Okay,
let's continue to just a bit more.
Oh, right, right there is fine. Yeah.
[inaudible]
so at this point you say,
what the heck happened to
my seat dod on Bom Bom Bom?
I don't remember that at all.
If so we've sort of lost track of that
as this astronaut or base keeps growing
in weight underneath. But gradually, uh,
what he does is take that Ostinato and
move it up into the upper part of the
register of the orchestra and then
gradually tr make this transform back into
the theme, sort of magically
transform itself back into the theme.
So let's go on now to 1755
and then we'll pick it,
pick it up there if that's okay.
Sounds very confused. But if you listen
to the upper register, you can hear the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
the theme is coming back
and the upper woodwind.
Okay, so now you think the pieces, yeah,
over
slow into tempo.
Way Down sell diminishes.
Could end it right here.
And that last little bit at the end of
course is called the Coda. Right. Okay.
So he once again with theme
and variations, if you
don't give the audience,
Dakota,
they're expecting next variation to begin.
So you got throw in that Cota so
that uh, everybody knows, hey,
that really was the end. No
fooling, uh, questions about that.
So that's Brahms' variations on the
theme of Haydn. It's, I can't say it's a,
it's a very, it's a beautiful piece,
but it's a very serious piece,
but it's a good piece for you.
This is very serious group this year.
I'm impressed with the seriousness with
which you show up here and as you take
this, uh, I gather,
I sometimes I see that you're actually
much more interested in the classical
stuff that we're doing then in the pop
stuff, which is not always the case, uh,
over the years working with
undergraduates. Okay. A question. Yes.
Uh, Daniel, yes.
W however disguise it is,
how the question is,
is the framework of the theme
always this ace c business,
no matter how far he goes,
melodically from the original pattern
and how complex in terms of counterpoint
and rhythmic permutations he becomes,
it still is dropped within this same
framework of the a c e c although it
admittedly it's pretty difficult
to hear sometimes. Yeah. David,
Michael, sorry. Uh, that, that I,
that is just with this piece here.
Uh, you can work with other composers.
Paganini is variations on a
theme of Rockmont and offer
example where the length
of the variations will become
very different and it'd be,
that won't be sort as bad as I like to
say box car, like as this arrangement.
This is still boxcar.
Like even though it's very diversified
in terms of what's put in and on those
box cars. Two good
questions there. Thanks.
All right, uh, having finished
theme and variations for the moment,
let's go on to talk about Rondo.
R o n d o a Rondo. Is
that really true? Well,
it goes by a couple of different
names. Uh, uh, English,
call it Rondo form, the Germans
call it Rondo form and Mozart wrote,
and I've looked at a lot of his
autographs wanting to write Rondo.
He spelled it r, O, n, d o c news.
Ela All falls on the,
uh,
Hondo say honed. Oh, miss
here. But if you go to Italy,
they would call it a doornail law.
Lochia Jamari toenail.
I love these, these, these, uh, latinate
languages are so wonderful, aren't they?
The way they play with the vowels.
Tonello so it's the same idea,
a Rondo, a home though and elite
Tonello. It's the same principle.
And oddly the principal develops right
out of the thing that we were talking
about.
Uh,
and that Frederick introduced this to
the idea of verse and chorus because
what's involved here is
really one musical concept,
one big theme coming back
again and again and again. Uh,
and this goes all the way back to the
Middle Ages where they would have soloist
singing new versus,
and then everybody would sing the chorus.
And the thing that we all remember is
the chorus. That's the big ticket item.
That's the thing that everybody is doing.
So that's the thing that keeps coming
back again and again and again.
So this in an odd way I think is the
easiest of these forms to remember.
If you hear some music where you get
music and then something else and then hit
in the face with that same music again,
then something else and you get hit in
the face of that same music again and
then something else.
And then the same music again.
That's probably Rondo form and you can,
you can give it these different names
in different languages, but the,
the idea is the same.
And as I suggest,
it's primordial I think on your sheet
to show you how primordial it is.
I even gave you the text of a Rondo by
Gilead and [inaudible] it goes all the
way back into the 15th century. We
don't have to go back that far. Uh,
and you can see, we'll end up today
with a Rondo by Stinger. So, uh,
this has been around for a long time.
This particular particular form. Um,
let's have an introduction to it by
listening to a reasonably well known piece
by Joel Joseph,
who was a composer in residence
at the court of King Louis,
the 15th at Versailles and in Paris in
the early years of the 18th century.
You probably know this music because
for years it was the background theme or
the introductory material for
masterpiece theater on public television.
So let's listen to a big,
uh, a bit of this. And, uh,
let me take this material off and we'll
chart here and I'll ask you what the
meter of this is,
but the meter and how many
measures of our refrain,
our main theme,
what we'll call it a here,
how many measures we have in our theme.
Let's stop it there. So what'd you think
about that? What's the meter? Well,
I would try to give that away.
Sometimes you listen to music,
you can't stop yourself.
It's like the end of doctor Strangelove.
You ever see that movie
get back? Um, so, uh,
yeah, it's a piece in
Dupal meter. How many,
how many measures did we
have in our theme? How many
measures did we count there?
Well, listen to, let's listen to it again.
Right back to the beginning,
I guess Linda.
Okay.
So what do you think? Eight. Alright,
let's put eight up here and let's
listen again now. Just continue please.
Oh, we stopped it there. We had
how many there? Eight again.
So everything is always four's and
eight's and music. No, not exactly.
If you start with counting
measures there in the Brahms,
his theme sometimes has five
measures in those sections,
but this one happens to be a different
and more common. Uh, eight plus eight.
And actually in reality here,
this is just slightly different than
the first day of the ending of it is
slightly different from the first day.
So there we are.
We've got our refrain or a theme in place.
Our big a idea.
Now let's go on to the next material.
Stop it there. How many bars did we
have there? Well, eight again. Okay,
so we could call the Di, di, di, di,
di, di, di, di, di, di, di, Di team.
Different sort of rhythm there.
We could call this a bi idea or we
could even call it an x does something
different, something different. And
that lasted for eight bars that get up.
Just a couple of Linda
if you would please.
So we can get back into that be
and then we'll go on to the next a.
So here we are with our B.
Stop it there. So what happened to
our a this time? How long was it?
Who still eat?
Did we get it again though?
Okay.
Yeah, we've got just one. That statement
of it. Why didn't we get it again?
Well maybe he didn't need
to give it to us again.
Ever watched television commercial when
they first come on and then what happens
to these commercials a
couple of months later?
What do they do if gain?
Yeah, they shortened them. They'll
run a 60 minute version of it.
Then is then a third show, 60 minutes,
that'd be interminable. A 62nd version.
Then the 32nd version, you
psychologically, sublingually, you'll,
you're filling in the missing information.
So keep an eye on for that kind of thing
and go, posers do that too. They know.
Well we've heard there's a fair amount of,
well we'll,
we'll give the psychological
a force of the whole thing,
but really just give it to
them in half. Okay. So, uh,
wherever we are there, it uh, but,
but yeah,
so back in around 45 or
so if you can get there.
Okay.
Here we got a count now.
So let's pause there. How long was
that section? 20. Yeah, 20 bars.
There's a long run of other material
and then as you can hear here,
our ACM is coming back.
Let's see if we get it repeated.
Was there a Cota there? No. Um, uh,
how did he,
how did this particular
group of performers make the
piece sounds as if it were
ending
dead. Daniel. Oh, Angela is it? Yeah,
he retarded. Dee Dee Dee Dee t
Todd. Tom Slowed it way down.
So if you don't want,
that's another way of getting a sense
of in here rather than throwing one,
some extra bricks to say the thing
has concluded harmonically. All right,
so that's one. Rondo, let's go
into a more sophisticated Rondo.
We're going to go onto
one by Vivaldi here. Now,
this is in the Greek Tonello form, as
you'll see when you read the textbook. Um,
but the principle is the same.
We have a theme that keeps coming
back again and again and again.
And you all know this theme.
You've probably heard it at Starbucks
or Oban Pan Eight zillion times, right?
Anybody sing it?
Anybody remember what the Vivaldi
spring concerto sounds like?
Okay, Angela is on the roll this morning.
So nice and loud. Don't be shy there.
Yeah.
Good. Okay. Dot, dot, dot,
dot, dot, dot. Tom Potter up.
Pop Art.
Then we have a second idea.
So here,
it's kind of our main theme here is
really kind of two ideas a and B.
But we're going to just for the sake of
argument here, just call this big a here.
Okay? So that, that, that's the theme.
So let's listen to a bit of this. Um,
well,
no,
we don't even have to listen
to this because Angela has
given us the return. Lol.
So let's go on to the first x here.
We've got something else coming in and
it's Vivaldi's attempt to write birds
chirping away on a beautiful
spring morning. So let's
listen to the birds here.
After the birds Chirp, we get our a
coming back. So let's listen to our a,
come back here.
Okay.
So now we're taking a walk through a
beautiful forest in the spring day and we
see a babbling brook and the
brook is foaming surging away.
So that's what we've got here.
Was that, that we just
heard bom, bom, Bom, bom.
Was that something else or was
that our rich horn elbow? Jerry.
Nice and loud. Okay. Uh, that was my
next question. You've jumped to it.
So it was the return Anello
and my next question is,
but what was different about
that Writ Ornella? Well,
the first time we had
it from bom, Bom, Bom,
Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom, Bom, it's a lower key.
So we've had a modulation.
This is actually down on the dominant.
We don't need to know that. We don't need
to know whether it's tonic or dominant,
but I think it would be good. We, we
heard that as just a little bit different.
Its lower, maybe a little darker
than the brighter sound up above.
So we had that and now
let's see what happens.
It doesn't have a storm come up and
sort of threatened this here in the
beautiful forest.
Okay.
Lots of Tremolo.
Lots of agitation.
Yeah.
What happen?
All right, we'll stop there. Yeah. Yes.
That was our red tornado coming back.
Our theme coming back. But
how is it different? Okay.
Yeah it was in mine are young
boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
So it had changed key again,
we don't need to know what key it went to.
If you were a betting man in Las
Vegas or betting woman in Las Vegas,
what would you say?
It went to?
The relative minor because
about half of the time, uh,
that's what they do.
And indeed in this,
this particular case it went just three
half steps down to the relative minor.
But hearing that it went to the minor is
all we're after here. So this was in a,
in a minor key here. And then
on it goes, we need in play,
play this out to the end.
It gives you a sense of how rare Tornillo
form can inform this particular Rondo.
Let's turn to another one
by Mozart here. Uh, yeah,
I think we've got time for that.
Um,
take this off.
So it's a horn concerto by
Mozart written in the 1870s. Uh,
and we're just going to start it out
here and we're going to hear the first
theme. But Papa, Papa, Papa,
Papa, Papa, Papa is the basis
of listening. Exercise 26,
which we'll get to uh,
in a week or so.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
okay, let's stop there. Why is
this an easy theme to remember?
Because it's full of
[inaudible].
It's a lot of notes,
right on the same pitch.
Bob Bomb and it's actually
starts to dominate.
[inaudible]
sort of goes along like that.
So we can keep a mental graph of
this with our exes now in a second.
And then the orchestra
repeated it then in a second.
The B theme is going to come in and
it's going to be very different. Yeah.
Pompom y'all pop, pop, pop, pop, pop,
Palm.
What's that?
Arpeggio? Okay, so instead
of using repeated pitches,
we mark the B section of this by
the use of lots of leaps here.
So we're going to have lots of space
between our exit, a bomb bomb bomb.
And then it's going to have a
couple of different motives in here.
But they're all very skippy. They're
all very disjunct. And it's these,
this junk leaps that mark the B section.
So let's just continue.
Okay,
jumps.
Now listen to the base here.
Who'd at another pedal point,
I'm sitting on the dominant.
What's this?
This is our theme a coming back.
Perfect.
Okay,
we're going to stop it here.
So here we are at this
particular particular juncture.
Notice each time the French horn plays
the theme than the orchestra repeats it.
Now as we go into this section,
we'll get a new theme.
It's c a and it will be marked
an interesting development.
Okay?
What's happened to the mode?
So what happened?
Did the piece there
change to minor change to mitre?
So we're, we're moving fast here,
we're doing all this and just one hearing.
So there we are.
Our C section is marked by minor,
so let's continue
rising sequence here.
Melodic seat
now falling
well,
I'll step lower
and lower yet again
and then a sneaks in
and here come our jumps.
So we're back to be
okay.
Okay.
Ooh,
let me just step out of cadence.
Pause it right there. Seeing the
next pitch, well not only bomb,
but that somebody starts saying by Tata,
Tata, you know what's happening next?
You said you have this big long dominant
pause [inaudible] and off it goes.
You'll play that Linda please.
Perfect.
Yeah.
Now this week we've had our a
in the orchestral repeat of it,
but we haven't heard this kind of stuff
before. What would you imagine is going,
what is this? We're listening to new
CODA. I'm moving things along here.
So we have a Coda and noticed it.
Dawn, I forget the particular key.
Mozart is working through the Duke
of Earl harmony at once again in this
particular particular section.
So let's listen to a bit of that.
And this is just filler arpeggio addict.
So that's our Coda again,
to show us that the pieces an end,
you can end your Rondo
and a couple of ways.
But the point here is notice the
form that has been created by Mozart.
And again, it is timeless. I think
we have time now to show a slide.
Uh,
and Jason isn't here today.
I wanted him to do this.
Uh,
I think I can turn this on myself though
and we're going to listen to Linda
start playing. Yeah, Dustin please.
So let's stop that just
for a moment. Uh, what do I
have up here on the board?
Anybody ever seen this before? Anybody
been there? Where would you imagine it is
in French at the Chateau de Shawn Bull,
c.
H. A. M. B. O. R. D. A.
I took this leaning out of a bus and you
can see over the left we have one idea,
the a idea contrasting idea
returned to the, a idea,
a largely contrasting idea here in the
middle, returned to your central concept,
uh, uh, a contrast here that
matches this contrast over there.
And then the central idea at the end.
It's exactly in one of these
palindromic a, B, a, c,
a, B, a form, the same thing that you
get here in the Mozart Horn Concerto.
And the same thing that staying in
the police ship program in to their
particular Rondo. Uh, you've
got the sheets on this.
Maybe I'll turn the lights back on
cause we don't need to see that anymore.
Did you like that? You want that back
on? Yes. Okay. Yeah, it's pretty,
I like it too. Okay. Um, and we
can, we can see well enough up here.
So let's listen to, I'll just tell
you, we've got this initial idea,
uh,
where is,
what key is e and h?
MMM.
Again, in the one six, four,
five, one Duke of Earl stuff.
But interestingly enough here,
half the time he doesn't come back
a deceptive cadence.
So he alternates here between authentic
cadences and deceptive cadence.
So we'll listen to a little bit of it.
If we run out of time, then we'll stop.
Okay.
Six, three, four step.
There's the six,
six,
four,
five.
Can we got to stop it here
or the copyright? People
will be all over us. Uh,
then it goes onto the beach
section. Oh, can't you see?
And for that we have the different chord
belong to me, my, her
mother heartbreak. Okay.
We can continue to play now.
All right,
let's move it up to the next
stay.
I want to get to see,
hey, what? Go straight to see. This is
pretty cool. What he does here. He's in,
in this particular key,
and he gives us this sound,
kind of a shocking chord change
right in the middle of the piece.
It's kind of a foot,
we would call a flat seventh degree.
Let's see if we can hear this
total shock and then we'll stop.
Yup.
Premier on out. You give blood
in the one, six, four, five,
one mentally in this section B section.
So that's it. I think we're
at a time and I thank you for
one third.